welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka mr. marvel and
this is the channel where we explain it
so you don't have to those who've been
watching III will have just seen marbles
and Avengers a day trailer drop and I
think the game looks really good it's
getting a lot of criticism at the moment
but I thought I'd just do something
slightly different from what I normally
do and go through the trailer bit by bit
and so break down and give my thoughts
on exactly what the games gonna be like
and if it's gonna be any good so let's
begin okay so the first thing that you
notice is that this game isn't connected
to the recent spider-man ps4 which is a
bit of a shame I was kind of hoping that
they'd have a tie-in but I'm guessing
you know they're gonna kind of try and
stray away from that especially with it
being a different studio this is Square
Enix are not insomniac but you know
fingers crossed that down the line they
do sort of bring these universes
together even though they're from
different studios don't hate me in the
comments and say that'll never happen
because I'll just pray in a praying
never meet your heroes
I feel like that old say never meet your
heroes is about Gaza but never mind
well I did
and it's one
so this is very notably the classic look
of the Avengers this is Thor before he
became funny iron man when he was just
sort of starting out with his mechanical
suit and Captain America when he just
just landed in the future after being
frozen in ice and yeah it's a good time
to set a first game I think oh I really
do you know you you're gonna develop
with these characters as they do - which
I think's a great choice that of course
is nolan north who voiced drake in the
in chart games he's done loads of voice
work he always kills a just fantastic
voice actor and have him as iron man is
a very good choice
thought there's a team where's Hawkeye
though where is Hawkeye Tony check it
out
[Music]
Troy Baker is actually playing Bruce
Banner as well and the Incredible Hulk
and I do think you know he it's tied for
me between him and nolan north for who
the best game actor of all time is game
voice over sorry um so yeah I think that
I think he's gonna be good and he has
got the dynamic range to pull off both
sides of the Hulk so that'll be a very
interesting thing to watch I've actually
seen a lot of people say that there's no
game play in this trailer but Spurs
throughout there are little snippets of
it and this is it looks very unreal or
mental to it and pushing forward as
you'll see in the trailer
right now you can see kind of the Hulk
running forward iron man pushing forward
and those guys all have skulls on their
faces which I'm guessing is crossbones I
might be wrong but you know that's all
his symbol and there are blue Hydra
lasers and which might be used from the
tesseract
okay so that did look like crossbones
you know not is completely comic based
look but very similar it might not be if
it's not tell me in the comments below
that I'm wrong and I'll be happy to go
back and delete this video forgot to
mention this was set in San Francisco so
maybe that's why avengers tower isn't in
New York with spider-man
and there's more gameplay sort of CAP
fighting you'll notice that it's very
similar to Arkham combat I hate everyone
who always says it's arc of combat but
yeah this is Arkham combat so I guess I
hate myself and this sort of deals with
the destruction of a shield Heric
Helicarrier that destroys the city and
yeah not very nice
that is a terian reactor I think they
say later in the trailer and this game
is sort of gonna focus around the big
failure of the Avengers so I'm guessing
this is in the opening scene and it
explodes they were set up to be fair
okay so this is very similar to sort of
the vanished from Avengers endgame and
it's it's a nice little tie in that
isn't too on the nose
hobo Tony Stark there he looks like a
bit like you know remember lost remember
Desmond brother Desmond looks a bit like
him Captain America is dead they don't
they don't hold that one that is in the
trailer and which is a nice flip on
Avengers end game you know no matter
what happens in these big apocalyptic
moments you know that one of the
Avengers is gonna have to die because of
it and this time it's cap so get a nice
flip on a vengeance end game those who
wanted Captain America die you've got
this game those who want an Iron Man
today you've got a vendor's end game
that's not how the story ends
doll riding a Helicarrier there into the
ground which that'll be amazed and
that'll be like they're the
stardestroyer have seen from the Force
Unleashed stuff you like right
abomination is here but I don't think
he's going to be the main villain um
those who've been kind of you know going
through the trailer bit by bit like me
wolf I think personally that it's going
to be Ultron that is the villain if
you've read age of Ultron this sort of
cataclysmic event happens in it when
Ultron becomes the leader of the world
and he destroys everything and so makes
all the survivors machines and the
Avengers have to go back in time and
stop him which i think is gonna happen
Hank Pym was also in another trailer
that they dropped like a twenty second
one and he of course created Ultron so I
think it's gonna involve going back in
time and stopping him you're so gonna
space
[Music]
I'm telling you that Ultron that and
it's coming out next year in May which
is amazing it's coming out on ps4 Xbox
one and PC so I'm really looking forward
to it I've seen a lot of people say that
the graphics look it looks like a mobile
game I think it looks really good really
high for it and we do need a good Marvel
game based around the Avengers that way
we haven't had one for ten years and
it's been such a hot property and this
looks like it's really gonna deliver and
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
so let me know in the comments below and
if you like this video then please give
it a thumbs up and make sure you check
out my breakdown of the casting news
that Michael B Jordan is gonna be back
in black panther 2 which would be linked
at the end I'm really sorry if my voice
sounds horrendous in this I've still got
tonsillitis
and it's about 6:00 in the morning when
I'm recording this so you know send some
nice comments by way as well please
thanks for checking out the video I'll
see you again next time this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like get subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition that you've been
the best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]